schön dass sie dabei sind ich bin der
bild sprach fox und ich möchte dass sie
mit dieser sendung geld und ärger sparen
in dieser sendung sind wieder menschen
zugeschaltet die haben tatsächlich große
probleme
geldnot durch jobverlust oder kurzarbeit
reise ärger ärger mit gartenmöbeln und
vieles mehr
viel spaß bei der sendung ja noch einmal
herzlich willkommen wir wollen ihnen
helfen entweder mit rad oder auch mit
tat also wir schalten auch gern
bild kämpft für sie ein ganz wichtig wir
wollen auch tipps geben das vielleicht
sie wenn sie keine probleme zurzeit
haben aber vielleicht probleme bekommen
könnten dass sie dann wissen was dann zu
tun ist und immer an meiner seite ist
arndt kempgens rechtsanwalt aus
gelsenkirchen hallo herr kempkens hallo
nach berlin
wir haben wieder eine menge zu klären
unter anderem ende ich mir noch gern an
gestern da hatten wir nämlich die tv
moderatorin margarethe schreinemakers in
der sendung wie wir aus belgien er
zugeschaltet wo sie lebt und sie hat
sich fürchterlich darüber aufgeregt dass
sie offenbar bei gartenmöbeln beschissen
worden war
das schauen wir mal rein alle zehn jahre
das ist jetzt 15 jahre ja und geführt
das muss man wissen es war corona hätte
ich glaube viele leute haben in dieser
besonderen zeit unter quarantäne
investiert der rassen ausbau verstellung
des beckens gartenmöbel zweier
bombenwetter und dann habe ich
eingekauft zu knapp 10.000 neueste
studie noch ein gartentisch und ein
sonnenbad
freude bis die sagen kann dann hätte die
frau darauf also ich hatte das gefühl
und auch meine begleiter ich war nicht
alleine wir waren zu dritt dass das was
wir gekauft haben und im geschäft
gesehen haben nicht der qualität
entsprach die dann ausgeliefert wurde
und dann habe ich noch von anderen
sollten gehört die sich eine
couchgarnitur gekauft haben nicht da
anderswo ausprobiert haben und
festgestellt haben bei lieferung es ist
nicht die couchgarnitur auf derbe
gesessen und meint verdacht wehrt sich
allmählich das hier unter umständen auch
gerade unter corona aspekten von zuhause
wichtiger wird der garten wichtiger wird
wo das um dich herum einfach wichtiger
wird dass da auch eine nummer geschoben
wird die den saft lästigen markt kaufen
wie seen im land schöne sachen und
kriegen eine verminderte qualität nach
hause da kann ich verstehen da ist jeder
aufgeregt natürlich nicht nur male räte
schreinemakers gut dass sie sich an uns
gewandt hat wir haben natürlich auch in
diesem fall recherchiert ich hatte
versprochen frau schreinemakers wir
schauen mal was wir machen können
nur ich sags ganz von vorne rein wir
sind leider auch gescheitert also wir
haben mit dieser firma oberster kontakt
aufgenommen
es gibt überhaupt keine hotline auf der
website wir haben dann in der filiale
angerufen wo frau schreinemakers
eingekauft hat dort hieß es wählen sie
diese nummer die war nur besetzt am ende
sind wir in den usa gelandet und hätten
uns da erkundigen müssen als
pressevertreter
ich finde das ist unglaublich wir
bleiben natürlich dran abend kempkens
das war auch genau das worüber sich auch
für schreinemakers geärgert hatte ja
total und man musste in diesem fall hat
mal wieder deutlich gemerkt dass
verkaufen geht viel schneller als das
reklamieren und das geltendmachen von
berechtigten mängel rügen sowie was er
hier hatten
denn die qualität stimmte nicht und es
waren eben mängel aufgetaucht und sie
hat ja auch noch berichtet dass
sozusagen die ware regelrecht porös war
und im jahr quasi bei bei regen sich
schon fast aufgelöst hat und dass es für
gartenmöbel natürlich nicht in ordnung
und da muss man wirklich dranbleiben und
das ist ärgerlich ist dass sie die
unternehmen versuchen die verbraucher
die kunden eben sozusagen einer langen
hand zu halten und eben nicht zu
reagieren und manche werden daneben
mürbe machen dich weiter und das sollte
man nicht tun sondern eben massiv
dranbleiben und ein wichtiger tipp
tatsächlich jeder kennt das da kommen
möbel aufbaue
die bauern zack zack zack was aussagen
wo wir sind schon verspätet wir müssen
schnell nach hause
sollte ich dann lieber die ware prüfen
denn auch tatsächlich margarethe
schreinemakers hat offenbar andere möbel
bekommen als sie bestellt hat ja
wichtiges vernehmen dass man nichts
unterschreibt
erstmal sollte man beim kaufvertrag und
wenn man die ware besichtigt fotos
machen von der besichtigten ware damit
man hinterher auch das bekommt was man
bestellt hat dann sollte man wenn es
geht zeugen mitnehmen
und was ganz wichtig ist bei der
vertrags eingehung dass man sich nicht
so auf ja so flammen welche zusagen
einlässt wenn man beispielsweise fragt
ist das denn für draußen geeignet zum
beispiel und der verkäufer sagt
selbstverständlich dann sollte man das
eben vertrag schreiben denn man merkt
dann schon sehr genau ob das ist ob
diese zusage die man abverlangt hat ob
die jetzt tatsächlich gehalten werden
kann oder nicht denn wenn jetzt wirklich
beispielsweise die möbel geeignet sind
das ganze jahr draußen stehen zu lassen
dann kann man das auch in den vertrag
schreiben und wenn der verkäufer da
schon zurückschreckt dann sollte man
eher die finger davon lassen
und wenn man die ware dann bekommt bitte
ebenfalls wieder fotos machen und vor
allen dingen nichts unterschreiben wo
quasi drinsteht ware ordnungsgemäß
erhalten
man sollte dann gar keine unterschrift
leisten oder wenn man schon
unterschreibt immer drunter schreiben
unter vorbehalt auch ganz wichtig
tatsächlich also das kann auch jedem
passieren was margarethe schreinemakers
da passiert ist
hier kommt zum nächsten zuschauer
nämlich michael reiser fahrer aus
nürnberg hat reise ärger wie vielleicht
auch so viele andere von ihnen und zwar
hat er uns dazu eine handy botschaft
geschickt
ich habe für einen der mehr als einen
kurz trip nach london gebucht gehabt
über booking letztendlich habe ich dann
einen tag vor reiseantritt eine
schriftliche bestätigung bekommen dass
mein hotel kostenfrei storniert wurden
ist und dass ich den betrag innerhalb
von fünf werktagen zurückerstattet
bekomme jetzt sind mittlerweile über
zwei monate vergangen
hawking hat mir in diesem zeitraum 4 mal
schriftlich per e mail
zugesichert dass ich das geld
zurückerstattet bekomme jedoch die
schades bis dato nicht und die letzte e
mail die ich von booking erhalten habe
war die dass es ihnen leid tut dass sie
mir das geld doch nicht starten können
da der star das hotel in londons nicht
verstellt ist das denn möglich das
booking vier mal schriftlich zu sagt zu
versichert dass ich das geld
zurückerstattet bekomme und mir jetzt
aber hinter nach einem rutscher anbietet
also so ein fall bringt mich total auf
die palme weil natürlich schon die
zusage da was sie bekommen ihr geld und
dann irgendwie doch nicht also da muss
ja wirklich in diesem fall bei booking
wirklich massives chaos herrschen da
weiß die eine hand nicht was die andere
tut und so kann man halt mit kunden
absolut nicht umgehen an can dance hat
genau zugehört wir sind da die
rechtslage einmal versprochen und dann
wieder gebrochen ist das okay nein das
geht nicht ich werde wir haben wir ein
rückgewähr schuldverhältnis das heißt
hier ist ja die rückzahlung auch
einvernehmlich quasi geregelt worden
aber man sagt dazu deklaratorisch weil
er hat der kunde hier der reisende hat
sowieso ein rückzahlungsanspruch das
entspricht auch der europarechtlichen
harmonisierung denn wir haben zwar
einzelne länder recht aber durch die eu
ist das ja weitestgehend harmonisiert
auch im reiserecht übrigens also hier
haben wir einen anspruch auf rückzahlung
und wenn wir jetzt noch zusätzlich eine
schuld an erkenntnis sozusagen haben
eine bestätigung in dieser form dann
gibt es überhaupt keinen zurück dann
kann man also dem reisen ich sagen er
ist so geld ist christoph gutschein oder
gar nichts das geht natürlich nicht
also rechtslage völlig klar geld zurück
ja aber es dauerte natürlich dann
relativ lange herr reiser hat sich dann
an bild kämpft gewandt wir haben dann
mit booking diesem fall besprochen und
es kam tatsächlich eine mail zurück und
das ist halt wirklich ein wirklich
positives endergebnis erst wurde ein kam
ein allgemeiner satz und dann hieß es
die rückerstattung ist jetzt auf dem weg
also bild wirkt und ich glaube herr
reiseverkehr sich glücklich schätzen
dass jetzt endlich dieses drama
ausgestanden ist wenn sie auch probleme
haben mit reiseveranstaltern mit der
schulbehörde mit lehrern mit
dem nachbarn mit dienstleistern dann
wenn sie sich an uns wir haben eine neue
e mail adresse die ist nämlich spar
folks at bild.de ich lese alles
persönlich und wir können dann sofort
darauf reagieren sie können es natürlich
auch nach wie vor ein handy-video
schicken wir eben gerade gesehen an per
whatsapp an 01 71 9 59 22 11 ich freue
mich auf ihre zusendung und dann können
wir hier gemeinsam für sie was bewegen
wir haben jetzt einen sehr dramatischen
fall und zwar andreas kuhlmann aus
wuppertal zugeschaltet er ist
schausteller hat einen imbisswagen und
natürlich jeder weiß dass es finden
zurzeit wegen corona überhaupt keine
volksfeste statt herr kuhlmann wie ist
die situation bei ihnen einen schönen
gruß aus wuppertal erst mal dass ich
sehe mich hier vor weihnachtsmarkt
equipment das war der moment wo die
schausteller deutschlands und ich das
letzte mal geld verdienen durften wir
sind seitdem corona ausbruch sind wir
mit einem 100 prozentigen veranstaltungs
verbot belegt worden wir schausteller
assoziieren das mit einem berufsausübung
verbot seit diesem moment sind wir ohne
umsätze wir können keine gelder
generieren
wir haben keine finanziellen
möglichkeiten unsere familie zu ernähren
unsere unternehmen zu sichern
wir gehen jetzt in den siebten monat
ohne umsätze wir sind belegt bis zum 31
10 10 das muss man sich mal vorstellen
das wären dann glatte zehn monate ohne
umsatz weil wir davor bereits in der
winterpause uns befanden die lage ist
dramatisch wir stehen mit dem rücken zur
wand wir uns wirklich noch zum atmen
genommen und wir wissen jetzt erstmal
nicht wie es weitergeht also tatsächlich
kann ich die wut absolut verstehen
natürlich im winter klar da finden keine
volksfeste statt aber dann kam corona
und so kommen halt diese diesem monat
zusammen wäre es für sie denn als als
imbissbuden betreiber nicht einfach sie
stellen sich halt woanders in mutters
wie auch publikumsverkehr ist vielleicht
vor einem supermarkt oder so oder sind
sie auf volksfeste angewiesen diese
möglichkeiten gibt es zum teil aber
diese jahrmarkt veranstaltung und
traditions- volksfeste
die es bereits seit hunderten von jahren
gibt das ist eigentlich unser part
unserer selbstständigkeit
im moment gibt es die nicht nicht nur
das münchner oktoberfestes abgesagt
sondern komplett alle veranstaltungen in
deutschland ja dass jetzt alles in einer
großkundgebung unter dem brandenburger
tor mit 1800 zugmaschinen am 27
kundgetan mit über 5.000 zu und
aussteller mit vielen vielen menschen am
straßenrand die uns fröhlich zugewunken
haben wir sind jetzt gerade in münchen
auf einer großkundgebung aber wir haben
einfach nicht diese zustimmung aus der
politik es muss jetzt dringend dringend
ein rettungsschirm her der uns
versprochen worden ist ein umfangreicher
und ein unbürokratischer und schneller
rettungsschirm sonst würde es die
schausteller brand im nächsten jahr
nicht mehr geben
und dann müssen sie ihren enkelkindern
erklären wie eine zuckerwatte geschmeckt
hat oder wie es war auf am
kinderkarussell gesessen zu haben
wenn das nicht passiert wird es im
nächsten jahr keine kirmesplätzen
ergeben sie sehen mich vor
weihnachtsmarkt kidmans die
weihnachtsmärkte sind ebenfalls auf der
kippe zum teil
und das würde der sicher betonte stoss
für uns bedeuten
herr kullmann noch einmal wie geht es
ihnen dabei persönlich wie lange halten
sie noch durch eigentlich gar nicht mehr
die soforthilfe ist aufgebraucht auch
ich bin angewiesen auf diesen
rettungsschirm
sonst werden auf jeden fall die
unternehmen nicht mehr gehalten werden
können und wir stehen absolut mit dem
rücken zur wand und müssen das erstmal
nicht mehr wie es weitergeht es gibt bei
uns ein beispiel in wuppertal eines
temporären freizeitparks die portale
schausteller anders jetzt auf die beine
gestellt und der vorstand unseres
vereins setzt jetzt um zeigt der
öffentlichkeit wie wir schausteller
diese maßnahmen umsetzen können wir
haben jetzt die möglichkeit besucher
zuströme zu regeln wir demonstrieren da
ein portal ab dem morgigen tag dass die
leute sich an jeder stelle die hände
desinfizieren können alle unsere
unternehmen sind ausgestattet mit
plexiglas und wenn der abstand nicht
eingehalten werden kann arbeiten wir nun
und nasenschutz
deswegen verlangen wir von der politik
unbedingt jetzt dass alle traditions-
volksfeste vor dem 31 10 stadt ziehen
dürfen das verbot muss aufgehoben werden
klare kante zeigen sie hier aber was
macht das mit ihnen wenn sie halt auf
dem hof sitzen und überall geht das
leben wieder weiter
können sie da schlecht schlafen sind sie
nervös sie haben auch gesagt sie wissen
jetzt auch nicht wie lange sie noch
weitermachen können sie stehen mit dem
rücken zur wand
ich merkte wut ich merke da zorn wie
geht es ihnen dabei persönlich die
dramatik finanziell ist natürlich groß
aber sie können sich vorstellen
die schausteller sind auch dafür da
folge zu bereiten und uns folgt ist ein
kind aus einem kinderkarussell steigt
und ein lächeln im gesicht das fehlt uns
auch ja ich erfahre selber bei mir an
der verkaufstheke
da sind menschen die freuen sich dann
über praktisch also das ist alles weg ja
diese ganze es ist auch ein schwerer
eingriff in unsere kultur eine 1200
jahre alte tradition wird hier sterben
und das ist noch das andere was nicht
mit geld zu tun hat ich möchte da noch
mal ein beispiel kurz anführen
wir sind sehr wohl systemrelevant wir
sind das günstigste antidepressiva was
ein mensch erfahren kann
das alles gibt es im moment nicht es
wird auch ganz viele in der gesellschaft
passieren wenn es die kirmes nicht mehr
geben wird
absolut das glaube ich auch an kempkens
wie sehen sie die lage ist da die
schausteller die große
schaustellerfamilie einfach schlichtweg
vergessen worden
also haben natürlich auch schöne
erinnerungen gerade so an die kindheit
wenn wir so über über die kirmes
gegangen sind und dann diese vielen
fahrgeschäfte da gesehen haben und das
leckere essen also kann ich mich auch
total gut daran erinnern ich mache
natürlich heute auch noch mit meinen
kindern und das würde wirklich schlimm
sein wenn es tatsächlich dazu
tief greifenden schwierigkeiten kommt es
wird seitens der bundesregierung gerade
an einer nachfolgelösung gearbeitet was
auch diese soforthilfen anbelangt und da
hoffe ich dass wir da in der nächsten
zeit mehr bekommen ansonsten ist es
natürlich wahnsinnig schwer die
einzelnen branchen individuell
anzupassen und jede branche hat ihr
problem das stimmt aber es ist halt auch
sehr schwer das so richtig in den griff
zu bekommen
ich hoffe auf eine nachfolgelösung zu
den soforthilfen herr kuhlmann ihr
dramatischer appell ist bei uns
angekommen wir schauen mal was das
bewirkt vielen dank dass sie in der
sendung waren und ihrer branche und
ihnen persönlich alles gute und bleiben
sie gesund
wir machen weiter wir haben in dieser
sendung schon mal berichtet über eine
großartige aktion wir schicken corona
helden in den urlaub und das ist
bestandteil eines gewinnspiels und wer
gewinnt kann dann quasi bis zum 30 juni
man kann sich tatsächlich das datum und
auch das ziel aussuchen in den urlaub
fahren und einer der für uns auch ein
corona hält ist und den habe ich jetzt
in der leitung michael amtmann aus
baiersdorf in bayern
sie waren bei uns schon mal in der
sendung und haben doch wirklich so toll
erzählt wie sie mit der geldnot gerade
klar kommen erzählen sie doch mal ihre
frau wäscht trikots sie bringen
kupferkabel zum schrottplatz und
verdienen damit ihr geld was machen sie
noch alles erst mal hallo freue mich
dass ich jetzt das highlight
ja also meine frau die bücher verkaufen
bei rivalen bei momox wird und
kupferkabel auswählen und das kommt halt
grau sie abgeben
solche sachen mal verwischt der
fußballmannschaft für uns vom ortsverein
ja aus solchen sachen immer wollten das
einfach nur wissen tipps geben tja leute
einfach dass die sagen können ich bin
sehe ich vielleicht aber das noch dazu
verdienen und es war eigentlich so dass
sinn des ganzen
das macht uns wirklich sehr viel mutiger
mann wie auch sie damit umgehen sie
jammern ich sie packen einfach an und
für uns sind sie auch ein corona hält
und sie haben uns im interview erzählt
sie waren noch nie im urlaub waren
wir waren mal kämpfen zusammen am
wochenende zutritt auf dem campingplatz
das war unser urlaub mit der ganzen
familie
und jetzt habe ich eine tolle nachricht
für sie weil sie für uns in corona hält
den zusammen mit ihrer familie bekommen
sie von uns an dieser stelle einen
kostenlosen urlaub geschenkt was ja toll
das ist ja der wahnsinn da freuen wir
uns das ist ja super kostenlos mit bild
und tui in den urlaub das läuft
folgendermaßen sie können sich ein ziel
aussuchen wir planen da auch noch eine
überraschungsreise sie haben zeit bis
zum nächsten jahr
aber diesen urlaub mit verpflegung
übernachtung und flug brauchen sie nicht
zu bezahlen
wow das ist ja der wahnsinn wie wir
haben das sollte uns natürlich mal frau
mega freundin die kinder das ist total
der 19 vielen vielen dank
wo ist denn ihre frau gerade die hat
heute arbeiten die mitglieder die sz in
einer halben stunde sie zu hause
ok dann drücken sie sie ganz herzlich
von uns und wir freuen uns auch sie mal
kennen zu lernen mit ihren kindern
ich würde nur sagen schönen urlaub herr
amtmann super vielen vielen dank euch ja
da freuen wir uns natürlich auch und
natürlich machen wir weiterhin auch
corona helden glücklich aber sie müssen
sich dann bewerben noch bis samstag 12
uhr läuft unser gewinnspiel alle infos
dazu wie sie da mitmachen können und
auch zu den gewinnern zählen können
finden sie auf bild.de
jan kempkens das war schon wieder tolle
gefühle zum schluss ich würde sagen
damit können wir die sendung schließen
oder ein versöhnlicher abschluss also
besser geht's nicht
absolut und ich freue mich schon auf die
nächste sendung dann in der nächsten
woche bis dann hoffentlich wieder mit
ihnen ihre neuer sprach fox schönes
wochenende gespielt
[Musik]